et j'étais le petit dernier qui faisait
rire toute la famille et je m'amuse et
j'imitais Alain Delon justement et c'est
pour ça que on me disait mais c'est tout
à fait ça il ressemble à Alain Delon en
me faisait croire que je ressemblais à
l'un de l'autre
la bonne entière est en proie à la
cacunaya on a voulu savoir qui se
cachait derrière Madame Sarfati voici et
les Kakou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est incroyable non c'est incroyable 5
ça va tu survis à ton admiration oui il
faut s'y faire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire je comprends
pourquoi tu as des petits dollars sur ta
voilà ce que ça marche
alors dis-moi
Kakou c'est ton vrai nom parce que
Marseille un CAP ou c'est quoi un petit
dur non un petit loup barre
c'était un pseudonyme et ça ça collait
quoi alors j'ai dit OK
ça a accroché pas pour un comique tu as
des surnom à part ta mère qui t'a appelé
mon petit poussin tu as d'autres surnoms
c'est tout mon petit poussin
[Musique]
ton signe astrologique Capricorne comme
moi
ça va bien faire monter le devant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si tu es menteur tiens est-ce que tu as
des signes particuliers moi j'en connais
deux fais gaffes des signes de quoi
physique particulier
Elie on ne me ment pas
il est plus drôle quand il est donné
[Applaudissements]
ressembler quand j'étais petit
que je ressemblais Alain Delon et
jusqu'à 14 ans j'ai cru que j'étais le
plus bel enfant de la terre
une copine qui croit qu'elle ressemble à
Brigitte Bardot
il faisait quoi ton papa
il était
adieu dans le chef dans un premier temps
et devenu exploitant agricole par la
suite
et ta maman elle n'a jamais travaillé ma
mère va s'occuper de toi c'est un boulot
raconte-moi la la rencontre de tes
parents parce que celle-ci joli quand
même un abeul en Tunisie ils sont
rencontrés c'est une belle histoire
c'est mon père qui était invité aux
fiançailles de ma mère et il y a eu un
incident diplomatique le fiancé est
parti et mon père s'est disputé avec sa
femme
et il est parti et mon père a pris la
place
d'un coup il a dit donc il a dit je me
marie avec elle était militaire c'est un
homme d'honneur quand il a vu cette
fille qui se retrouvait toute seule il a
dit moi si vous voulez je l'épouse c'est
ça alors tu avais deux frères 4 sœurs tu
étais le petit dernier tu étais quand
même super chouchouté
quand même
oui moi j'ai pas honte moi je me laisse
pas faire c'est comme
tu sais que je me suis disputé avec la
marchande de légumes je voulais acheter
des poires chez la marchand de légumes
je voulais les choisir
la
vendeuse elle me dit mais
non Madame Sarfati et si on touche pas
les fruits
[Rires]
comme ça énorme je rentre à la maison
j'ouvre la première et tu es toute
pourrie
j'ouvre la deuxième
madame
vous rappelez de moi je voulais acheter
des poires vous m'avez dit non ici on
choisit pas regardez et pourquoi vous
m'avez choisi
elles sont toutes pourries
moi je suis pas dans la poire
maintenant vous y êtes
[Applaudissements]
si cet enfant super chouchouté qui t'a
rendu comme ça égocentrique égoïste
exhibitionniste
de de faire quelque chose de chanter de
danser j'étais le petit dernier qui
faisait rire toute la famille et
j'ai imité Alain Delon justement et
c'est pour ça que on me disait mais
c'est tout à fait ça il ressemble à
Alain Delon en me faisait croire que je
ressemblais à l'un de l'autre
allumée alors vas-y tu en as une et
je voulais alors tout le monde disait
non ne lui donnez pas une cigarette
c'est pas bien à 5 ans quand même
et moi je disais si j'ai pas la
cigarette allumée je ne fais rien alors
je montais sur une échelle et quand
j'étais en haut de l'échelle on me
donnait la cigarette et je faisais
c'est tout et tout le monde
tu devrais tu devrais aller dans sa
famille c'est troublant leur semblant
tu devrais aller passer le week-end dans
sa famille mais c'était pas la vie de ma
femme et tout le monde disait mais c'est
super mais si Alain Delon regardez et
moi je continuais
j'ai pris plaisir et voilà maintenant je
fume à cause de ma famille
ils t'ont tué bon alors c'est vrai que
tu as un côté tu dis souvent je préfère
tu dis je joue un peu au mec qui s'y
croient mais tu t'y crois un peu quand
même non mais bien sûr je crois qu'il
faut s'y croire pour y croire parce que
moi avec tout ce qui m'arrive je n'y
crois pas encore
ce qui m'arrive c'est fin je reconnais
plus que plus là
il y a plus une émission de télé où il
est pas je suis désolé c'est pas de ma
faute
c'est comme ça c'est la vie dis-moi Elie
ta maman elle voulait que tu sois avocat
médecin ou dentiste
si ça avait été possible de faire les
trois
j'aurais voulu elle aurait voulu une
place stable elle aurait voulu elle
voulait pas en tout cas que je fasse le
comique
alors non j'ai fait des études de
prothèse dentaire
oui ça se voit d'ailleurs
et tu as décidé de laisser tomber
pourquoi la preuve les prothèses
dentaires ça te plaisait pas quoi ben
parce que il fallait que je fasse un
crédit je me suis dit si je commence je
pourrais plus m'arrêter
alors c'est Muriel montaucet qui
travaillait pour Philippe Bouvard qui
t'a fait passer la télé c'est comme ça
que ça s'est passé la première fois non
Muriel m'a vu dans au plateau 26 à
partir
pour le festival du mot de Bobino de
Bouvard et il y avait Guy luxe à la
première qui m'a vu dans le voilà
c'était un conte de fée voilà c'est ça
un compte de fée et alors elle m'a mis
Guy Lux m'a dit tu te présentes à la
classe il y a aucun problème et moi et
la classe me refusait depuis deux ans
déjà donc c'était j'avais déjà mis une
croix dessus j'ai dit c'est fini la
classe et puis je suis arrivé quand on
m'a vu on a pu lâcher voilà et je savais
toujours des personnages différents qui
accrochés
le prof en soutane le curé l'attaché de
presse il y a quoi d'autre
comme ça fatigue
presse
là le voyou marseillais
le défilé de mode
alors vous répondez présent à l'appel de
votre nom à Babou
comme il y en a Bourgeat
[Applaudissements]
IVe je l'ai vu
alors je vous préviens
que je dis
les gens qui n'auront pas leur cahier de
géo
géographie
porte avec un rapport de chez Monsieur
bien Chloé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qui a dit
Abdelkader
j'ai parfaitement vu entendu ce que vous
avez dit oui je comprends l'arabe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour la fois prochaine
vous apporterez la photo d'un personnage
que vous découvrirez
dans une bande dessinée vraiment photo
quelconque
la photo d'un personnage
en mouvement
médiatique quand même non
oui je réalise ça ce soir
quand on ne voit trop au bout d'un
moment les gens normaux je sais pas
demander aux gens du métier mais il faut
demander au public non
oui j'ai peur mais
c'est toujours une peur différente et si
on avance et on a des nouvelles craintes
et on a de je veux dire j'avais aussi
peur quand j'ai commencé au Point
Virgule
[Musique]
par rapport à Marseille Paris c'était
séduit ou déçu le milieu du showbiz par
exemple tu
fais assez
ça fait peur ça fait peur oui ça fait
peur de voir que tous les gens sont
intéressés
je sais plus qui vient me parler et qui
qu'est-ce que veut la personne
moi je vais l'attacher de presse
vous savez ce que c'est une attache de
presse
moi je convoque la pression
j'envoie les invites je colle des tables
c'est moi qui lance les artistes
c'est moi qui est dans ces Casimir
Casimir nos enfants c'est moi
[Rires]
à toute la presse tout ça toute la
presse il y a que maison et jardin qui
est venu
j'ai téléphoné à Drucker
des ménagement
pourquoi j'ai pas envoyé
vous n'êtes pas au courant
moi
c'est Paris la belle rouge tout ça c'est
moi mais moi je travaille moi c'est à
moi c'est mon corps je fais ce que je
veux chez une être humain
[Applaudissements]
merde
non non
non non parce que j'ai
c'est moi qui ai voulu donner aussi
j'ai voulu donner et j'ai réussi à
donner quoi j'ai réussi à faire passer
ce que j'avais envie de faire passer
ils m'ont pris beaucoup aussi
[Rires]
je vais te dématérialiser
attention attention tu fermes les yeux
le curé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu